bill cosby a free man the video of his
motorcade leaving prison
as the world is stunned by this sudden
decision no matter how you feel about it
i don't think any of us saw this coming
and our rachel smith joins us now from
outside the prison near philadelphia
with the latest developments bill cosby
was released just before 2 30 pm eastern
today
tv helicopters followed his caravan and
he arrived home
a little more than an hour later this is
really
shocking this was a kick in the gut to
all of the victims
and to their advocates cosby stepped
outside briefly this afternoon and
flashed the peace sign
he did not speak while his attorneys
addressed the media
reaction is mixed bill cosby's tv wife
felicia rashad
celebrated the release tweeting finally
a terrible wrong is being righted
a miscarriage of justice is corrected
we broke down today's ruling with two
experts tv legal analysts rachel
stockman
and lisa bloom who's represented three
cosby accusers
including janice dickinson i want to
remind everyone this decision
is not saying that he is innocent it's
saying that a former prosecutor
made him a promise that he would not be
prosecuted
it is not a finding of innocence the 83
year old had served more than two years
of a three to ten year sentence at a
state prison near philadelphia
prosecutors cannot refile charges that
would be double jeopardy
and bill cosby cannot face another trial
for this
particular case as for the women who
stepped forward against cosby
e.t was with one of the first supermodel
janice dickinson
in 2015. i was drugged and raped
drugged and raped by bill cosby
i'm so sad i'm so sorry for women
and young girls janice is gathering her
thoughts
because this is a very hard day as you
can imagine
we also spoke to model beverly johnson i
was drugged
and i feel very fortunate that i wasn't
raped
cosby claimed she was just joining a
campaign to assassinate his character
over 60 women in all spoke out and there
was this stunning moment in prime time
27 of cosby's accusers together on nbc's
dateline
how many of you believe you were drugged
by bill cosby
how many of you believe bill cosby raped
you
the consensus from my clients is this is
absolutely appalling it's a terrible day
for justice